celebrities SNL stars and the man who
could have been Spider-Man here's a
rundown of the absolute best cameos in
Spider-Man across the spider-verse when
we catch up with miles after Gwen's
across the spider-verse opening he's
late for a meeting with his parents and
his school guidance counselor they're
all supposed to be chatting about his
future college applications but miles is
too busy battling the spots across
Brooklyn he's lying to you
think you know it if you thought the
guidance counselor's dry tone sounded
familiar you might be a fan of Saturday
Night Live as esteemed Alum Rachel
Dratch is the voice behind the character
while she played a wide range of roles
during her tenure on the show Dratch is
probably most famous for her Debbie
Downer character the only thing higher
than gas prices in this country are
divorce rates
[Music]
[Applause]
it's also interesting to note that while
obviously distorted and caricatured to
fit the animated style the school
counselor Bears a striking resemblance
to Dratch herself given how perfectly
the counselor fits in her repertoire
it's not unlikely that the role was
written with trash already in mind
if you're a big Spider-Man fan you
probably already know about Donald
Glover's complicated relationship with
the character back in 2010 when Sony was
casting roles for The Amazing Spider-Man
the now acclaimed multi-hyphenate was
publicly favored for the leading role
Donald Glover can play Spider-Man he's
nerdy fans quickly rallied online on his
behalf and even Stan Lee through his
support behind Glover and he was never
given the opportunity to audition Glover
eventually did join the Marvel Cinematic
Universe as a low-key Cameo version of
Aaron Davis miles's uncle and the secret
identity of the prowler in Spider-Man
homecoming so it only makes sense that
he'd reprise that role and across the
spider verse Glover's Cameo is mostly
played as a gag but it's also a clear
nod to the actor's long and complicated
history with the modern Spider-Man
franchise the version of the prowler
that he plays here isn't the same as his
homecoming Incarnation as he actually
has some of the purple armor that the
character typically wears
after scuffling with miles around
Brooklyn the spot vanishes by
disappearing into himself however he's
not trapped as an endless stream of
holes provides gateways into other
universes most of the parallel worlds
are animated albeit in a variety of
styles but one portal takes the spot to
a live action realm right into the
convenience store run by Peggy Lou's Mrs
Chen if you haven't seen the Tom Hardy
Venom films this scene was probably
pretty confusing but in reality Mrs Chen
is a Mainstay of the Venom franchise her
extensive experience with the titular
alien anti-hero is why she's so
completely unfazed by the spot's
appearance Lou even started as Mrs Chan
in a web series promoting Venom Let
There Be Carnage Lewis set to return
again as Mrs Chen in the upcoming third
Venom film
there may not be a more iconic superhero
movie performance and JK Simmons as J
Jonah Jameson the oscar-winning actor
first played the daily bugles
cantankerous editor-in-chief in 2002
Spider-Man and he reprized the role in
both of Sam raimi's sequels since then
Simmons displayed a different version of
Jameson in the MCU in which the
character is more of a conspiracy
obsessed Alex Jones parody
we'll be right back after a brief word
from Daily Bugle supplements the only
other daily fix you need at this point
it's weird to imagine anyone else
playing the part so it should come as
little surprise that Simmons once again
embodies Jameson and across the spider
verse some of his lines are pulled
directly from the Ramey films including
in one scene featuring a Lego version of
The Daily Bugle in which he demands
pictures of Spider-Man however there's
also some new dialogue in the film
during Gwen's opening sequence we see
how she's become blamed for the death of
Peter Parker and her Universe a muddled
massive accusatory audio plays over her
Sombra scene and Simmons's voice can be
heard referencing the mysterious Spider
Woman given how beloved Simmons's
Jamison is it's a treat to see that he's
willing to return to the role again and
again
a musical comedy group might not be your
first pick to feature in a superhero
movie but then again across the spider
verse isn't a typical superhero movie
really maybe it shouldn't be all that
surprising that two members of The
Lonely Island appear in the film The
First Lonely Island member we encounter
is yorma takoni who voices the strange
Renaissance Era version of the vulture
who battles Gwen at the beginning of the
movie Tacony previously voiced multiple
characters in into the spider-verse
including the Green Goblin later on we
meet Ben Reilly AKA The Scarlet Spider
who's voiced by fellow Lonely Island
Alum Andy Samberg Scarlet Spider
arguably plays a larger role in the film
as he's part of the task force created
by Miguel O'Hara to hunt down miles
after his escape the character is pretty
similar to the kind of comedic bear that
bands of sandberg's work should be
accustomed to a boisterous oblivious goo
with a handful of pretty good laugh
lines
as if there weren't enough Saturday
Night Live alumni and across the spider
verse already stalwart straight man
Taran Killam also shows up killum voices
both web Slinger a cowboy version of
Spider-Man and his horse Widow who also
wears a webbed mask the two bizarre
variants only really speak in one brief
scene so you'd be forgiven for not
noticing taryn's presence in the film
later on web Slinger and Widow joined
the stampede after Miles when he
attempts to escape Miguel's grasp though
killum is certainly most famous for his
tenure on SNL he's appeared in dozens of
TV shows and films he's also lents his
voice talents to the animated Star Wars
shows the bad batch and young Jedi
Adventures
cameos aren't just for actors as the
late Stan Lee himself could have told
you in addition to the various SNL
alumni and Hollywood icons who sneak
their voices into across the spiderverse
to acclaimed animators are also hiding
in the background first Pixar Legend
Peterson makes a brief Cameo as miles's
roommate Genki the acclaimed animator
recorded lines for the character during
production on into the spider-verse but
those bits were ultimately cut so it's
nice to see him reinstated in the sequel
are those my Jordans
I can't help it if we're the same size
someone's career in film animation began
with the Iron Giant and he's worked on
everything from The Incredibles and
Finding Nemo to the good dinosaur which
she directed he's also the director of
the 2023 Pixar film Elemental throughout
his career son has made a habit of
voicing smaller characters here and
there and as big as such role to date is
probably the robotic cat socks in light
year but he's not the only animator with
a voice Cameo later on in the film
during miles's escape from the spider
Society we encounter a Spider-Man
therapist voiced by animator Mike Rianda
and then I looked at
let me guess he died Rihanna gained
widespread Acclaim for co-writing and
co-directing the Netflix animated film
the Mitchells versus the machines which
was produced by Across The spider-verse
Writers Christopher Miller and Phil Ward
Zoe Kravitz played the famous Mary Jane
in Spider-Man into the spider-verse but
because it's been five years since that
movie was released many may have
forgotten MJ has a small role in across
the spider-verse only really appearing
in one scene to talk with Peter B Parker
about their daughter but yes even in
that brief moment it's still Kravitz in
the time since the first movie came out
Kravitz says expanded her superhero
repertoire by delivering a spectacular
turn as Catwoman in the Batman starring
opposite Robert Pattinson it's nice to
see that her DC ties haven't kept her
from returning to the world of
Spider-Man though and there's a good
chance that she'll have a larger role
again and Beyond the spider verse next
year though we're parting across the
spider versus small it's far from
insignificant MJ delivers one of the
core monologues in the movie explaining
the inherent chaos of becoming apparent
in the impossibility of being fully
prepared for change
acclaimed hip-hop and R B producer Metro
Boomin worked on the across the
spiderverse soundtrack but that's not
where his contributions ended he also
lends his voice to a new Spider-Man
variant in the film that goes by the app
name of Metro spider the character
appears briefly to deliver a quick
one-liner during the spider Society
Chase there's nowhere to run
my bad everybody there was somewhere to
run Metro boomin's grungy production
style leaves its fingerprints all over
the soundtrack in the best way imbuing
action scenes and somber moments alike
with a rich depth of audio intensity the
DJ made his Fame producing radio hits
but he's clearly just as at home working
on a sweeping cinematic score he
contributes hugely to the overall
aesthetic of across the spider-verse and
it's nice to see that work rewarded with
an on-screen cameo
well not exactly cameos in the
traditional sense across the spiderverse
does feature some visual nods to the
live-action Spider-Man movies of the
past well Toby Maguire and Andrew
Garfield appear in archival footage
which mostly shows up during Miguel's
Multiverse Exposition as he explains the
Canon events that connect all Spider-Man
variants different instances manifest
around him in Miles these include the
deaths of Uncle Ben and Captain Stacy as
seen in the previous Sony films because
of the specific moments chosen Cliff
Robertson's Uncle Ben and Dennis Leary's
George Stacy also appear it's
particularly touching to see Robertson
who passed away in 2011. his version of
Ben Parker remains extremely iconic and
influential and it only seems right to
give him his flowers in a movie about
the franchise as a whole across the
spider-verse stops short of filming any
new material for McGuire or Garfield and
that's probably for the best the use of
their footage here is tasteful evoking
just enough Nostalgia without overdoing
it as first shown in the trailers across
the spider-verse features a staggering
number of different Spider-Man variants
some are core characters with key roles
to play in the story many are entirely
New Creations just meant as goofy gags
and a fewer callbacks to specific
moments in the wall crawler's long media
life two of the latter appeared during
the spider Society scenes both
representing a different animated TV
iteration of The webhead's Adventures
the Striking Nano suit from Spider-Man
Unlimited the sequel to Spider-Man the
Animated Series that ran from 1999 to
2001 can be seen in Miguel's base
chasing after miles also visible in
Spider-Man's 2099 HQ is the squat round
Spider-Man from 2008's The Spectacular
Spider-Man cartoon just as he was in his
own Series this particular variant is
voiced by Josh Keaton and across the
spider verse I Am The Spectacular
Spider-Man
[Music]
in addition to the different comic book
variants and cartoon Spider-Man who
appear in the spider Society there are
two characters pulled straight out of
Insomniac Games acclaimed 2018 video
game the PS4 versions of both Peter
Parker and Miles Morales can be seen
walking and talking through Miguel's
base and later on the video game version
of Peter even speaks as you'd expect
he's voiced by Yuri lowenthal here same
prolific voice actor who plays the
character in the PlayStation title this
isn't the movie's only nod to the 2018
game either when miles bursts into his
dorm room through the window at the
beginning of the movie his roommate is
playing the game on their shared TV the
PlayStation Spider-Man has been hailed
as a huge achievement for the franchise
and it spawned a half sequel starring
miles himself as such it's only right
that the game gets its own little Cameo
and across the spider-verse
[Music]
foreign